hello everyone and welcome to two great
games from the legendary Tournament of
peace that is currently uh being played
in Zagreb some 60 kilm from where I live
and there is a possibility that I visit
the tournament and um visit the players
but my daughter is uh is sick for the
moment so I don't know if I will manage
the time I hope I will uh but we'll uh
we'll get to that if if you have any
questions that I might ask some of the
players of the tournament also use this
uh comment section and uh you know have
the questions ready
I might be able to pull it off but
getting back to this game this is Hans
Neiman versus Vasan chuk the legend uh
who really enjoys visiting Croatia for
the tournament of peces the tournament
of Peace really has a long tradition
started back in 1970 H it was visited by
none other than the great Bobby fiser
who at the time was practically
unbeatable uh he he hasn't lost a game
in 1974 for like three years uh and he
won the tournament but he did lose one
one game at the catian international
Master Vladimir kovachich is a Legendary
game if you haven't seen it do check it
out first link in the description below
uh quite an amazing game but yeah it was
first they organized in 1970 then in
1975 then in 1985 after 10 years then
they abolished the tournament for 33
years it was revived in
2018 uh where where bascar and adiban
won the tournament then they had W in
2019 that vas lean chuk won and this is
like the six edition of the tournament
uh where now Hans is really having an
amazing amazing run and there's a famous
story from the first edition of the
tournament in 1970 where Bobby fiser
visited uh he requested an extra $11,000
just to participate in the tournament
and the tournament organizers um denied
him this and he said that he will not
play and they almost replaced him but in
the before the start of round one the
Slovenian Grandmaster Bruno Parma uh
told Fisher that the the Russ Russians
were very happy that he's not playing
and this sort of rattled Bobby and he
decided to play the Russians being the
Russians in the tournament I think the
former world champion tigan petro
and Bot vinck I think were playing uh
and um yeah may maybe one more maybe uh
coroi yeah Victor kchoi was also playing
in the tournament but then yeah Bobby
decided to play uh he won the tournament
and lost only that one game I really
suggest you you check it out it's the
first thing in the description below uh
Bobby fiser crushed by none other than
the French defense uh even he is not
immune to the opening uh but yeah that
being said let's check it out it's Hans
Neeman now uh walking in the footsteps
of the great Bobby fiser visits Croatia
visits Zagreb and wants to dominate the
tournament so let's see this is the
first game and the second one we are
going to cover will be against Croatian
grandmas Robert zelic so Hans has the
white pieces in this one and he opens
with Pawn to
E4 uh we have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3
and Knight to F6 uh even goes for the
Petro's defense Knight captures on E5 D6
and now Knight to F3 we have Knight
captures on e4 and now Pawn to D4 so
okay the classical attack against the
Petro D5 we have Bishop to D3 Knight to
C6 and now casts with Bishop D7 and now
uh standard moves here are c4 which is
the top move and Rook D1 which is the
second the most often played move but
Hans plays Knight B to D2 he wants to uh
check how how well vasel remembers the
lines and okay Knight captures on D2
Bishop captures and Bishop to G4 pinning
the Knight we have H3 uh sorry not right
away first hunt play C3 you do want to
guard the D4 Pawn as now the Knight
really can't help with the defense
castles and pawn to H3 now Bishop to H5
and now uh Pawn to G3 not Pawn to G4 all
the way it would be a bit too ambitious
so Pawn to G3 first we have Queen to D7
putting pressure on the H3 pawn and King
to G G2 uh we have Bishop to G6 now uh
countering the light Square Bishop here
and Bishop to F4 we have Bishop captures
on D3 Queen captures and now okay the
position has been reached before for
example Anish giri had it against yongi
in the Tata steel Tournament of 2020 uh
where Pawn to A6 was played and that
game ended in a draw but here we have
Bishop to D6 and it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game and
uh okay you could just trade here and
maybe move the Rook to to the open e
file but Hans first goes for Knight to
G5 he threatens Checkmate so Vel has to
defend and only now he trades captures
captures and now Rook a to E1 we have
Rook 8 to E8 of course contesting for
the D file uh for the open E file and
now Pawn to H4 trying to get that pawn
all the way to get some sort of an
attack going against the black king uh
Knight to d8 now the idea is Knight to
E6 the trade of the powerful knight on
G5 and Hans goes for Pawn to H5 we have
Knight to E6 and now Hunts uh if he
doesn't want to trade Knights he has to
go back which he does so that which
means that he's still interested in
winning this game he's not um ready to
settle for a draw just yet and now
vassel could choose for G captures on H5
it's sort of an engine move you know you
mess up your Pawn structure something
that a human does very very reluctantly
uh so he goes Pawn to C6 instead and
okay we have Rook to H1 by hunts and now
vasel goes Pawn to G5 yeah he does want
to open up the H file of course Knight
to E5 by hunts and now Pawn to H6 and it
seems like you could go for Knight to G4
very powerful uh eyeing the F6 and H6
squares but if you do this then Knight
to G7 and now the queen guards these
squares and if Queen to F3 okay you can
simply play uh Rook to D6 you you again
guard everything and if you if you trade
here then even F captures on E6 gains
control of uh of F6 so it's not really
an issue and you don't even have to play
that like if Rook captures you can even
capture with the queen and one check
doesn't really do all that much you can
simply move the king so instead Queen to
F5 first and now okay you can't just
idly wait for something to happen Knight
to G7 attacking the queen and now hun
finds a brilliant resource and that is
Queen to D7 and okay how do you how do
you deal with this you have to trade
Queens obviously or you could play Queen
to E7 but he decides to trade Queens
Knight captures on D7 attacking the rook
and The Rook captures on E one first we
have Knight to F6 check this is very
important if you if you capture The Rook
first then you allow The Rook enter the
game with Tempo so Knight to F6 check
King to h8 and only now Rook captures on
E1 with the Rook coming to E7 uh uh if
you don't stop it so Knight to E6 and
now Rook to E5 okay uh defending
properly uh nothing uh nothing wrong
with the position Pawn to A5 and now
Knight to G4 um uh setting his eyes on
that H6 Pawn so King to H7 if you play
Pawn to F5 and sort of try to trade
Knights then captures captures and you
lose the H6 Pawn as well you create a
past H Pawn and that's it white will win
this game so uh King to H7 first uh
vasel has to defend that pawn and now
Rook to F5 going after Rook F6 and Rook
captures on H6 we have King to G7 and
now Rook to F6 going after the pawn Rook
to h8 and now Hans plays Pawn to A4 and
he sort of uh locks vassel in in a sort
of a semi Swang as there really isn't
all that much to do here uh we're still
not at a point where a move the
definition of a two Swang is that every
move you make loses you the game uh but
it's very hard to find a move that
doesn't so here Pawn to B6 by Vel and
now Hans finds the beautiful Pawn to F4
uh not much to think about here G
captures we have G captures and now the
problem is you can't just idly wait if
you play Pawn to B5 then Pawn to F5
comes you even give up the H5 pawn and
then after Knight to F6 Knight to F4
check King F3 and you capture this Pawn
uh Rook captures on C6 and okay a big
captures on A4 Pawn to F6 with check
King H7 Rook C5 you go after the pawns
and the white has a completely winning
end game so uh uh ivanchuk tried
something else he played Rook to C8
first but now Pawn to F5 H and now
Knight to G5 not going for Knight to F4
check as it doesn't really achieve all
that much
uh Knight to G5 and now Rook captures on
H6 we have Knight to E4 uh King F3 and
now Rook to C7 we have King to F4 and
now Knight to D2 uh very very important
move for the Knight because you want to
shift the Knight to C4 and go after the
B2 Pawn but also have the option of
going back to E3 if needed if the white
king becomes too active so here we have
Rook to D6 uh moving The Rook out of the
way of the H Pawn and now Knight to C4
we have H H6 with check King to H7 and
now uh the position is completely
winning for hunts but you have to
correctly um assess the position feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the correct continuation uh while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
uh well any of the winning moves like
you could play a rook to F6 or Knight to
F6 check but those are slow the quickest
one is Rook to d8 this is what Hans
played and it was in this position on
move 42 that vasle vuk resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
a point is that if you if you do nothing
here let's say you play B5 which is your
only active move here you're getting
checkmated King to G5 and there is no
defense against Knight to F6 Checkmate
whatever you do whatever move you play
it's Knight to Knight to F6 Checkmate so
the only thing you can do here after
this Rook to d8 move is try something
like Knight to D2 point being that now
King to G5 will will be met with Knight
E4 check but then you go after the B
Pawn Rook B8 and again leave black
without a move let's say Pawn to C5 you
will simply play Rook captur on B6 and
now if see captures on D4 Knight to F6
check ends the game because if you go to
h8 then this is Checkmate once black
gives up the rook and if you try
something else um uh well what else is
there to try if you try a knight to F6
check and now King captures an H6 you go
under the mask of the rook and then
Knight the E8 with check will pick up
the Rook on C7 uh and that's all there
is King H7 you're going to capture the
rook and have a completely winning end
game as you are up a full Rook uh so
that's what happened in round three hun
played this sort of a drawish line
pretty much all of the games that were
played in this um sort of a not an
offbeat opening but uh not very often
played ended in a draw including that
game an played against y uh hunt was
able to to master the full point here
and now we Advanced to the second game
and that is Hans nean versus Robert
zelic of Croatia uh so let's see what
happened in this one it's also quite
quite an amazing game Hans played Pawn
to E4 and now Pawn to C6 Robert goes for
the caroan defense with have D4 D5 and
Hans goes for the advanced variation of
the caroan now Bishop to F5 is the the
absolute main main move here but zel
goes for C5 first this is the the binic
defense uh and now Knight to F3 Hans
also chooses a not not the absolute main
line as D captures and C5 is main here
so Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now D
captures and C5 we have Pawn to E6 and
Bishop to E3 uh Knight to H6 a standard
move in the caran that you will see or
maybe even in the French trying to get
access to that um F5 square and now Pawn
to C3 we have Knight to F5 going after
the bishop and Bishop comes to D4 so if
you capture hunts can just UND double
his pawns here uh Bishop to D s and now
there are some games that reach this
position quite a lot of them in fact
Queen to D2 is a well-known move Bishop
to D3 A3 all known moves here but we
have Bishop to B5 by hunt and it is now
as of move nine that we have a
completely new game and there's quite a
lot of thought um invested in this
bishop to B5 move and and preparation of
course uh because it's not easy to deal
with it of course um you were asking
what happens if just Knight captures on
E5 can this be played then if Bishop
captures then you capture back so it
does seem to be uh gambiing a pawn well
let's see what he had in mind Knight
captures on E5 Robert takes the pawn uh
and now not Bishop captures but Bishop
captures on E5 sorry not Bishop captures
on E5 Knight captures on E5 Bishop
captures on B5 now going uh for the
bishop and preventing Hans from castling
and now Pawn to A4 and now look at this
fun line if you want to remain here on
A6 and control this diagonal look at
what happens Hans will play B4 and then
after B6 Hans will play Pawn to A5 and
look at this ugly position and now uh
how do you continue here the the main uh
defense here is F6 and then you run into
a captures and B6 opening up a discovery
on the bishop a captur so The Rook
defends Queen to H5 with check G6 Knight
captures H captures and queen captures
on h8 Pawn to E5 where black gets a huge
Center and still keeps the white king in
the center of the Border but now B5 and
look at this bishop captures Rook
captures on A8 Queen captures you gain
access to F6 uh and you get this
position where of course if the bishop
is captured then Queen captures on G6
with check King D7 Queen captures on F5
uh it's a really really wild position
where uh well yeah the blacking is in
the middle of the board okay Queen to A2
can can be played and looks very
dangerous with the bishop here and
everything uh but uh well objectively
it's a dead draw obviously Hans knows
knows this and he knows how to play this
position and he would definitely have
the upper hand especially if zel never
saw this and he would have to work all
of this out during the course of the
actual game so he went back Bishop to D7
not um you know not trying to poke the
bear uh and now Pawn to A5 Huns grabs
more space here A6 stopping A6 by white
and now we have castles uh Bishop to E7
we have Knight captures on D7 Queen
captures and now Pawn to B4 always a
very strong move for white we have
castles and now Knight to D2 uh Bishop
to d8 now Shifting the bishop over to C7
to try and um put pressure maybe on on
the white king and Bishop to E5 stopping
that we have F6 Bishop to G3 and now
Robert captures the bishop Knight
captures H captures and Bishop to C7
grabbing hold of this long diagonal uh
Knight to C4 this is a beautiful move by
Hans because it takes uh advantage of
the only moment in the game where you
can shift the Knight over to B6 if you
don't want to go all the way around via
the A6 Square because now uh the queen
is hanging if you capture on C4 so Rook
a to d8 and now he does get the Knight
all the way to B6 and now we have Queen
to C6 the queen is attacked uh Rook to
E1 and now Pawn to
H6 uh you could also consider something
like uh like Pawn to E5 but um uh maybe
it's um too too too early for that
Robert wants to still prepare it so
First Pawn to H6 Queen to D3 and now
Pawn to E5 we have Rook e to D1 it's a
very odd move probably most of you
including myself would play Rook a to D1
but it's you know it's uh that's where
you know uh that's where the real
difference between a grandm and a
regular player comes into comes in mind
uh which Rook belongs to to to which
file uh probably he played Rook 8 to D1
instead of Rook 8 to D1 because if
Bishop captures knight uh a captures
maybe he uh would allow the queen to
access the game via the A4 Square so
maybe he wants the Rook Guardian A4
square but again who knows Rook e to D1
by hunts Bishop captures on B6 a
captures and now Rook to D7 we have
Queen to F5 uh grabbing more space here
with the queen and now Rook to E8 sorry
uh Rook to E8 and now we have Rook to D2
going for Rook to D1 and this is now the
uh moment where Robert has to play Pawn
to D4 and it's not the same here move
order really comes um into effect you
could try to double up first and then
play D4 or you could play D4 and then
maybe uh decide UND doubling up later if
needed but uh he played Rook e to d8
first now he wants uh once okay let's
say Rook 8 to D1 is played he wants to
play D4 but now Hans is completely
winning uh if he plays it correctly so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea that Hans played while I
give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not playing
anything weird like I do in my games in
Rapid and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Pawn to F4 this
is the question that Hans asked and why
D4 should have been played before Rook e
to d8 uh the problem is if you now play
D4 then look at this F captures on E5
and if D captures on C3 looks great but
now comes Rook to D6 with Tempo the
queen is attacked and now uh the the
there's just not a good move here if you
play this then he captures you have this
amazing fast Pawn here uh if you don't
capture what else are you doing the
queen will move you you gain access to
D6 Square the C3 Pawn will fall white is
absolutely dominating so that's the
problem here so after F4 E4 was played
by Robert and now Rook to D4 now the
entire position gets blocked and D4 can
no longer be played ever again for the
rest of the game so King to F7 and now
Queen to H5 with with check King back to
f8 now comes Pawn to G4 now Hunt is
ready to play G5 and open up the
position towards the black king queen to
E6 now comes Rook a to D1 doubling up
here so you have to be careful otherwise
C4 might also be a move in the future we
have E3 grabbing more space here
advancing the past pawn and now Queen to
F5 very annoying move by Hans uh you
cannot trade Queens of course if you
sorry if you trade Queens then G
captures on F5 and black is really
without a move here as the E3 Pawn is
now too advanced he will win the pawn
and then play C4 and easily win the game
so instead after Queen to F5 Queen to E7
was played and now Rook to E1 uh we have
Pawn to A5 as there really are no other
moves the C5 Pawn is um trying to be
weakened uh but Pawn to G5 just opening
up an attack towards the black king a
captur some B4 G captures on H6 and here
rer play B captures and C3 getting a
second pass Pawn but Hans just plays
Pawn to H7 we have King to F7 Queen to
H5 check G6 and now Hans can win the
game but only if he plays one precise
move feel free to pause the video and
win the game while I give you a couple
of
seconds uh the move that Hans played and
that wins the game is of course Pawn to
H7 but not bringing a queen into the
game he brought the Knight into the game
as this comes with check and it's always
very much uh a pleasure to win the game
this way because if you bring a Queen
into the game then black just captures
here and once you capture with checking
f8 and you just don't have enough
material to win this you're down a full
Rook uh however if after this you play
uh Knight checks now you you have to
play something how do you how do you
continue with this do you capture the
Knight here then uh Queen captures Rook
that's not really going to work so King
to G7 was played and now Knight captures
on G6 we we have Queen captures on C5
and here hunt played a really really
wonderful move he played Knight to H4
point being that if Queen Capt Rook he
has Knight to F5 check uh winning the
queen here so King to G8 was played and
now Knight to F5 we have Pawn to C2 now
uhel preparing to bring a Queen into the
game and here Hans played Queen to G6
check King to h8 Queen captur on F6
check King to G8 Queen to G6 check King
to f8 and now Hans finish finishes the
game off with a brilliant Knight to H6
and he was in this position on move 46
uh that Robert zelic resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the problem is it seems like you can
grab a full Rook but if you do this then
the idea is of course Queen G8 check
King E7 now Queen uh sorry Knight to F5
check forcing the king to d uh forcing
the king to to F6 and now Queen to G5
with check King F7 and now Knight
captures on D4 uh will win the black
queen and also the C1 square is being
covered so there is nothing uh you can
do here so grabbing the grabbing The
Rook doesn't work uh what about bringing
a queen into the game this also doesn't
work because you can just play Queen G8
to check King E7 and now go for this
Checkmate King D6 and queen to F6
Checkmate as the pawn prevents the king
from reaching the C7 square and other
than this there's really not much else
you can try you can try to block Queen
G8 with Rook to G7 but then Queen to F6
check King to E8 and now Queen captur on
G7 again with all the same ideas The
Rook is defended you don't have time for
this as Queen to F7 will be Checkmate
and if you try Rook D7 then Queen G6
check King to G8 Queen to e Queen to G8
uh with check King to E7 and now even
Rook captures on E3 with check King F6
and Rook to E6 will be Checkmate so uh
nothing works here for uh for Robert but
everything works here for Hans and
that's why Robert resigned the game so
you can see that Hans is really really
playing strong chest here kept both uh
both vasle vuk and Robert zelic in in
well sort of sort of a tuuk Swang for
quite quite a bit of time and in the end
he was able to pull off a full point and
he's doing incredibly well here uh for
the moment he's in first place after
five rounds have been played with four
and a half out of five so he defeated
Alexander MV he defeated vasle manuk he
defeated Zeno K he defeated Robert zic
only one that got a draw against him his
creation Grandmaster herich so we'll see
how he does will he be able to follow in
Fisher's footsteps and win the legendary
Tournament of Peace in Zagreb and will
he be able to do it without losing a
single game something that Robert James
fiser was unable to do as he lost that
Legendary game to Vladimir kovachevich
if you haven't seen it first link in the
description below uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed the two
games I thought it was fitting to cover
both of them I would like to thank David
gasparian Yan piano on YouTube Joe
Lennox Meed haki us and Karim kawash for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual can
check two of my previous videos SAR
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions but also
everything else that's happening in the
Chess World like this wonderful
tournament here uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day